Career assessment tests and career counseling are some new ways of helping people find out which jobs would suit them.
There are quite a few benefits to taking assessment tests.
They could be a time-saving way to jumpstart the process...
...because they cut down on hours spent searching and thinking about pros and cons.
They provide a structure for thinking and planning...
...and you can quickly determine your best talents.
This will boost your self-confidence.
These tests can help you look at your strengths and options from a new perspective.
If you feel overwhelmed about where to start or focus on,...
...career advice tests help by narrowing down the types of careers that would be most suitable for you.
They also help you avoid making the wrong choices by pursuing a career that might be totally unsuitable.
The right combination of assessments...
...might just be the right way forward in supplying you with evidence of the components you need to find your niche.